where does
death come into that
so being is forgetting i mean the the
concept of time completely
there's a there's a sense that doing and
becoming that has a deadline and
built in the urgency
built in do you think death is
fundamental to this
to a meaningful life uh
or um feeling the terror of death
like ernest becker or just acknowledging
the uncertainty the mystery the
the melancholy nature of the fact that
the right ends is that part of this
equation
or it's not necessary okay look at how
it could be related
i've experienced fear of death i've also
experienced
times where i thought i was gonna die it
felt extremely
peaceful and beautiful and
um it's funny because
if we we can be afraid of death because
we're afraid of hell or bad
reincarnation or the bardo or some kind
of idea of the afterlife we have where
we're projecting some kind of sentient
suffering
but if we're afraid of just
non-experience
i notice that every time i stay up late
enough that i'm really tired
i'm longing for deep deep sleep and
non-experience
right like i'm actually longing for
experience to stop
and it's not morbid it's not a bummer
it's
and and i don't mind falling asleep and
i
sometimes when i wake up want to go back
into it and
then when it's done i'm happy to come
out of it so
um
when we think about death and having
finite time here
and we could talk about if we live for a
thousand years instead of a hundred or
something like that so be fine night
time the one bummer with the age we die
is that i generally find that people
mostly start to emotionally mature just
shortly before they die
um but
there's
if i get to live forever i i can just
stay focused on what's in it for me
forever
and if life continues and consciousness
and sentience and people appreciating
beauty and adding to it
and becoming continues my life doesn't
but my life can have effects that
continue well beyond it
then life with a capital l starts
mattering more to me than my life
my life gets to be a part of an in
service too
and the whole thing about when old men
plant trees the shade of which they'll
never
get to be in um i remember
the first time i read this poem by hafez
the sufi poet
written in like 13th century or
something like that
and he talked about that if you're
lonely to think about him and he was
kind of leaning his spirit
um into yours across the distance of a
millennium
and would come for you with these poems
and now
he's thinking about people millennium
from now and caring about their
experience and what they'd be suffering
if they'd be lonely and could he offer
something that could touch them
and it's just [ __ ] beautiful and
so like the most beautiful parts of
humans have to do with something that
transcends what's in it for me
and death forces you to that so not not
only does death create the urgency
it urgency of doing
it you're very right it does have a
sense
in which it uh incentivizes the
compersion
and the compassion
and the widening you remember einstein
had that quote something to the effect
of it's an optical delusion of
consciousness to believe there are
separate things
there's this one thing we call universe
and uh
something about us being inside of a
prison of perception
that can only you know see a very narrow
little bit of it
but this this might be just
some weird disposition of mine but
when i think about the future after i'm
dead and i think about
consciousness i think about
young people falling in love for the
first time in their their experience and
i think about people being awed by
sunsets and i think about
all of it right i can't not feel
connected to that
do you feel some sadness
to the very high likelihood that you
will be forgotten
completely by all of human history you
daniel
the name that that which cannot be named
systems like to self-perpetuate
egos do that the idea that i might do
something meaningful that future people
appreciate
of course there's like a certain
sweetness to that idea
but i know how many people did something
did things
that i wouldn't be here without that my
life would be less without whose names i
will never know
and i feel a gratitude to them i feel of
closeness i feel
touched by that and i think to the
degree that
the future people are conscious enough
there is a you know a lot of traditions
had this kind of
are we being good ancestors and respect
for the ancestors beyond the names
i think that's a very healthy idea
you